the paris commune a short-lived attempt
at revolutionary government that for
some holds a legendary place in history
famous for invoking images of french
workers taking up arms establishing
their own government and trying to
reforge france in a new image
its impact was and is far-reaching but
despite
said impact the commune only actually
existed for a little over two months
which raises the question
why why did the paris commune fail so
first
background in 1870 france was an empire
ruled by napoleon iii
there were some disagreements between
him and prussian leadership about who
would take the spanish throne someone
got offended and because this was 19th
century europe
that meant war the french did not
perform well in this war and napoleon
iii himself was even captured
and about six seconds after this
france's remaining leaders declared the
creation of the third french republic
but still continued the war
the prussian army now marched on paris
and placed the city under siege in
mid-september of 1870.
the city was mostly defended by the
national guard a voluntary militia made
up of the parisian
working class many of its members were
unhappy with the government and wished
for more representation and better
economic conditions for them if they
were expected to fight and die
they were given to use the technical
term squat and despite many protests and
increasing radicalization the
representatives of the french republic
remained in charge there and in january
1871 the city's leaders surrendered
the french held an election and the
pro-peace monarchists won
and as such many in paris feared the
return of the monarchy not napoleon iii
though
thrones are for winners with the war now
over the french government sought to
disarm all of those radical members of
the national guard
and so they came up with an ingenious
idea they asked politely and in return
promised not to shoot them shockingly
the national guard said no and when the
army moved in to seize their weapons
some fighting broke out many parisians
sided with the national guard and the
government and army fled the city
and on march the 18th the paris commune
was declared it held elections soon
after which were open to most parisians
providing they were men and a new ruling
council for the city was placed in
charge
most of these were radically left-wing
with many being socialists or communists
but about a quarter were moderate
right-wing candidates
however due to increasing radicalization
many of the right-wing members of the
council left and some even fled the city
in fact it was this diversity and
leadership which made running the
commune difficult
unlike later revolutions there was no
definitive leader nor much of a clear
agenda
however the primary debate of
legislators was over whether or not the
revolution was to be spread elsewhere or
shored up in paris first
in versailles not too far away the
freshly fled republican government was
deciding on how nice to be with the
revolutionaries
and the conclusion they came to was not
very the communards were little more to
the government than a violent coup led
by poor militiamen and such events could
never be allowed to slide if this
government was to survive
and in this opinion they have the
backing of most of the country the
commune had fairly broad support in
paris but nobody really knew what their
endgame was
and this is an important reason why it
would soon fail but how exactly did it
fail
well its end came when it was crushed
militarily the communists decided mostly
that sitting in paris was waiting to be
crushed and so decided in april to march
on versailles
they were clearly outgunned by the
french army but they banked on the
common soldier rejoining them as they
marched on versailles
now the military tacticians amongst you
will know that fighting a war based on
the premise of its fine they probably
won't shoot back
isn't the most sound strategy and it was
not as a side note whilst all of this
was going on there was a massive german
army camped outside the city
the reason that they were there was that
in the peace negotiations in return for
not storming the city the french would
give the germans to use a legal term fat
stacks of cash
and since the people of paris hadn't
paid up there they waited
anyway a couple of weeks after the
failed march on versailles the french
army launched an assault on paris
this assault is known as bloody weak
because it saw the french army
systematically eradicate most resistance
and undertake the mass execution of any
suspected communards
most communad leaders fled the country
and the government began the long
process of re-establishing control over
the city
and so like most small revolutions the
paris commune failed because it was
crushed militarily
and part of the reason why that could
happen was because of the fragmented
leadership of the commune there was no
central leader nor any overriding idea
of what the communades wanted france to
look like
and with that there was no decisive
action taken against the republican
government even when it was at its
weakest
nor was there any central ideology for
anyone outside of paris to rally around
and help them
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette mr wolf kelly money
maker skye chappelle rob d martin
captain cydog marvin cassell moe aaron
the white adam stalter jordan longley
boogery wiggly gustav swan jerry landon
rasheed ali gareth turner maggie
patzkowski coppertone winston k wood
spinning three plates corso wolff
marcus asner spencer lightfoot matthew
shipley the mug whopper alex schwinn
lil brep and tc robert wetzel anthony
beckett charles the first and scottish
trekkie